and Here I am today at Howard a
historically black college here I am a
guy who once presumed to discuss a
section of the Civil Rights Act didn't
always go so well for me some have said
that I'm either brave or crazy to be
here today I've never been though
wanting to sit by watch the world go by
without participating we're at a
university what great does this speech
get I give him an a a - I am I thought
his actual speech could have been a bit
better I thought he could have been he
could have gone into a little bit more
detail in some of the things he was
saying but it's Q&A session it's
definitely I think helped get us get
what he's really about out there this
was a great good-faith effort to reach
talented african-american community I
think the RNC should take note of what
he's doing frankly I was offended
embarrassed and shocked that he was
allowed to come speak at Howard
University I don't know I wanted to
speak about updated issues we didn't
like what it what's an updated issue
maybe gay marriage marriage rights
immigration policies policy I was
impressed though I thought that the the
Rand Paul that we saw here was different
from the Rand Paul that's portrayed in
the media and is that the media's fault
or do you think he's changing his tune I
think that he is tailored his speech to
the audience that he spoke to my hope is
that you'll hear me out there you'll see
me for who I am and not a caricature
that sometimes presented by political
opponents now he came out he was
anti-war he was anti drug war he's anti
mandatory minimum he's Pro school choice
are those issues that you think resonate
with the black community I definitely
think that that is something that not
only resonates with the black community
but the majority of Americans and also
like young Americans like myself so one
of the first things is actually
listening to the community in settings
like this and figuring out what people
actually care about what resonates with
them you can't just hit people up six
months before an election they expect to
be able to do well with that demographic
and I think it's really the contest
their vote i I think that Rand Paul you
know I'm hopeful he'll continue to do
more of this and he'll be a model for
other Republicans because they lost the
election because they ignored the
minority vote and while the RNC pours
over a growth and opportunity report you
know it's almost June and we've seen no
activity or outreach from the Orange
so kudos to rand paul now the Republican
Party got seven percent of the black
vote in 2012 do you think that they can
actually increase them you can probably
increase it by a few percentage points
but that to some extent depends on who
the Democratic presidential nominee is
is there anything that say a Rand Paul
or the Republican Party could do to get
your vote it would essentially require
basic fundamental differences in their
platform and in their party what would
he have to do to get your vote actually
he would never get my